welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania is
set to introduce major Marvel Comics bad
guys to the MCU in the form of both King
the Conqueror and the now confirmed
mental organism designed only for
killing himself Modoc yeah I have been
waiting for this big-headed [ __ ]
for the longest time but what if I told
you that there was actually a secret
third villain in that movie that was set
up in Ant-Man 2 Baba Yaga Boogaloo huh
let's talk about it my nerd babies but
first hit up new rockstarsmerch.com to
find our latest Obsession shirts and all
of our amazing gear over there we have
our new latest Obsession shirt inspired
by 411 Thunder worthy of Love That is
not going to be run forever so pick that
up as soon as possible find all that and
more over at New rockstarsmerch.com
today but alright so long story short I
believe that Marvel Studios has left a
super subtle hidden Easter egg that
teases the coming of ant-man's greatest
Nemesis to the MCU an Easter egg head to
be exact cause I am convinced that the
famed Ant-Man villain Egghead will be
joining King the Conqueror and his
fellow hello big-headed brother Modoc
for quantumania and to explain why I
believe this is gonna happen we
naturally have to go back to egghead's
first appearance in the MCU in Ant-Man 2
back when he was just poor old Elias
Starr father of avastar who was just a
pre-teen when her parents built a very
strange machine designed to view a world
unseen because she's gonna catch them
all because she's ghost from the sequel
to Ant-Man literally the same origin as
Danny Phantom
because during the flashback sequence
that shows the origins of ghost Powers
we learned that her father Elias was
working on building his own Quantum
tunnel to the quantum realm after having
a big falling out with his old science
partner Eng Pym the man who is literally
incapable of being friends with anyone
who is not his wife like dude have beef
with Howard Stark Bill Foster Bill Nye
the Science Guy anybody smart like Hank
was a big time hater man but since Elias
was unfortunately doing all this Quantum
realm research and technology stuff
without his him partner his ex-shaped
head wasn't smart enough to make it
quantum tunnel that you know didn't leak
out crazy amounts of yellow Quantum
radiation before exploding because a
smart man would do that which is to make
a machine that didn't explode what an
idiot but let's walk through what
happened during this flashback scene my
nerd babies because right after the Star
Family Quantum tunnel started to go
Haywire Elias did what a good father
would do and immediately took his wife
and daughter out of the laboratory and
told them to leave the building while he
himself stayed behind to try to stop his
machine from exploding a [ __ ] ton of
quantum energy all over the place but
while he was doing this Elias got
himself hit with a big ass wave of
quantum energy that knocked his bald ass
to the floor this wave of quantum energy
is extremely extremely important here
because this is what I believe will lead
to the transformation of Elias Starr
into the big-brained Anton Menace of the
MCU Egghead and also allowed Elias to
save the life of his daughter who would
run into the room to help him off the
ground with her mother not far behind
her that's right everybody I believe
that Elias himself saved Ava because you
see my nerd babies I have a strong
feeling that the quantum energy that
hits Mr Elias right before he hit the
ground evolved his body specifically his
brain region his head and triggered a
Quantum level mutation within the very
cells of his body a Quantum energy
mutation that allowed Elias to save his
daughter from the coming Quantum tunnel
explosion through physical contact the
last thing that happened just before the
explosion was Elias yelling at his
daughter to leave and just being scared
for her safety and his daughter touches
him on the shoulder I have a feeling
that that contact with Elias's newly
irradiated body combined with Elias's
extreme desire to save his daughter from
the coming explosion caused Elias to
alter his daughter's molecular makeup
with his mind creating ghost he wanted
his daughter to phase through the blast
so he accidentally gave her phasing
Powers as you can see Ava's mom wasn't
in direct contact with Elias right
before the blast so she didn't get Ghost
powers in order for her to not die yeah
she's the only person that died here do
you remember being a nerdy kid back when
the only way to show your love for
superheroes was an ill-fitting T-shirt
with a big super symbol on the chest
from a kiosk hidden in the darkest
corner of your local mall don't you
think the next generation of nerdy kids
deserves better than that I do and you
know who agrees with me epic hero shop
if you ever wanted to be the cool uncle
aunt family friend for the nerdy kids in
your life check out epicurershop.com to
see mid-sized variants of some of their
best design just imagine sending the
kids that you know back to school
wearing classic epic hero shop latest
Obsession teas like worthy of Love or
worthy of Thunder from Thor Tomb of the
Moon God for Moon Knight and the great
protector from Xiang Chi all amazing
shirts and if you live somewhere cold
pick up a hoodie to keep that kid warm
while they wait for the bus because uh
they're gonna be waiting for the bus a
lot and maybe just maybe some of you
aren't doing back to school shopping for
nerdy kids but nerdy adults in your life
heck I don't know maybe that nerdy adult
is you epic hero shop still has plenty
of merch in adult sizes the Thor love
and thunder latest obsession will be in
the dungeon soon along with the
strongest Avengers hat which is one of
our dopest dopest items so if you've
been thinking about getting one but
haven't pulled the trigger yet now right
now is the time this is the absolute
best way to support the channel and we
love to see all the pics that you post
in your merch so be sure to tag at epic
hero shop and use the hashtag real epic
hero to get featured on their page
because we love seeing you guys in our
gear it's the best so shop back to
school and more at Epic heroshop.com and
I think that this is possible because
yellow MCU Quantum energy is actually
the very same energy found within the
Mind Stone an energy both capable of
giving people superpowers as evidenced
by both Wanda and Pietro through hydra's
experimentations as well as allowing for
molecular alteration and phasing through
solid matter much like the yellow
Quantum energy powered vision and
Electro could do because Electro's
powers are just electron manipulation an
electron manipulation is a Quantum level
event which is why electrodes lightning
is yellow in the MCU as opposed to Blue
like fours and it's the reason why we
can see this very important Easter egg
of Elias's head glowing in the shadows
right after the blast and Ava's being
looked at by the local emergency rescue
team we can see his little head glowing
with power I do not believe for a second
that Marvel Studios killed off a major
Ant-Man villain in a flashback sequence
in Ant-Man 2 because homeboys bald head
is about to undergo a drastic change and
become bigger and a lot more egg-shaped
than it used to be to house a new and
improved Quantum Computing brain
irradiated with Quantum energy sort of
like Vision but you know way less red
and robotic we must not forget what the
ancient one told us in Doctor Strange
one at the root of existence mind and
Matter meet that meant something all of
the Ant-Man films of the MCU are all
about the mind's relationship to matter
it's the reason why Ant-Man can
communicate to ants how the quantum
energy empowered Janet Van Dyne was able
to possess Scott Lang's mind and Ant-Man
2 and how that very same Janet was able
to heal Hank and ghost with her Quantum
energy powers by specifically making
contact with their heads their minds
their brains this is the reason why I
believe Ant-Man 3 is called quantumania
because of the immensely powerful nature
of quantum energy and its potential for
human evolution like so many people on
MCU Earth want a piece of that pie so
they're gonna go crazy crazy over this
Quantum energy hence quantumania a
potential for human evolution that Janna
teases to hang right before they left
the quantum realm in Ant-Man 2. I'm not
the same woman I was 30 years ago Henry
this place
it changes you
I mean adaptation is part of it but some
of it is
evolution
this is all the case I would not be
surprised for a second if quantumania
reveals that Quantum energy itself is
the key to unlocking the XG mutation in
the MCU because the X Gene is all about
Evolution baby as Quantum energy affects
the physical makeup of objects and
things on a Quantum level and can
interface with the human mind much like
when the Mind Stone Amplified Wanda's
latent Powers within her brain but at
the very least I would definitely expect
Egghead to appear in quantumania fully
alive and well and ready to get his
hands on more of that mutating Quantum
energy that will likely be used on one
George Tarleton where the creation of
the big-headed Modoc himself because if
a little bit of quantum energy can
create Egghead what would happen if a
scientist exposed his brain to a massive
dose of quantum energy Modoc that's what
happens but also I can sort of see Kang
the Conqueror using Quantum energy to
trigger the rise of mutants in the MCU
on purpose because what's the point of
wanting to conquer the universe again if
you're going to fight the same old
boring Heroes again because he's already
Fought The Avengers so Kang might
actually want to put some X-Men in there
too just spice things up and also we
can't forget that Cassie Lang herself
was exposed to a little bit of quantum
energy when her father returned from the
quantum realm in her bedroom in the
first Ant-Man film so there's a bit of a
possibility here that Cassie could have
been a mutant this entire time ever
since that moment a mutant with the
ability to change her physical stature
thanks to the evolving power of quantum
energy we shall see thank you guys so
much for watching this video you can
follow me at masterton on Twitter you
can follow Newark Trails wherever we are
on social media be sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can pick up
our latest Obsession shirt inspired by
Thor love and thunder but anyways thank
you guys so much for watching this video
you guys are amazing and I love you guys
so much and I'll see you guys next time
[Music]
thank you